salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
en 2013 un restaurant londonien a servi
un plat très spécial le premier
hamburger à base de viande de synthèse
de la viande élaborée en laboratoire la
note était plutôt salé 250000 € objectif
de ces recherches sur une planète qui
consomme de plus en plus de viande
trouver de nouveaux moyens de produire
des protéines animales alors on en est
loin et est-ce vraiment souhaitable il
existe existe d'autres solutions
consommer moins ou bien des protéines
végétales c'est parfois à s'y méprendre
restez avec moi on va tester tout ça en
2019 en Suède une marque de Fast F bien
connue met au défi ses clients de faire
la différence entre un burger classique
à base de viande et un autre à base de
protéin végétal commandant leur menu les
clients ont une chance sur deux de se
voir servir le burger végétal à eux de
deviner ensuite ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur l'expert expérience
rencontre un immense succès et le
résultat est tout simplement incroyable
44 % des clients qui se sont prêtés au
jeu ont été incapable de faire la
différence du coup j'ai décidé de faire
le test alors à vue de nez ces deux
steaks se ressemblent beaucoup même si
j'ai une petite idée ils ont à peu près
la même
apparence et la même texture mais lequel
contient de la vraie viande la réponse
se trouve sous les assiettes à moi de
deviner c'est parti
pas
mal j'ai connu mieux le
voisin ça ressemble à de la viande mais
bon c'est quand même un peu trop fondant
en bouche et puis c'est aussi moins
juteux non je pense que la viande se
trouve ici et le végétal ici
ver
yes cela dit la texture est quand même
assez proche de celle de la vraie viande
je comprends que l'on puisse confondre
ça ressemble disons à une viande un peu
trop cuite bon en même temps il faut
comparer ce qui est comparable on a
comparé deux hamburgers de fast food ça
n'a rien à voir avec le steak haché de
mon boucher et puis c'est un steak haché
une bavette j'aurais pu réaliser la même
expérience avec des nuggets de poulet et
des nuggets sans poulet c'est assi mé
prendre et là encore on compare des
nuggets entre eux on ne compare pas avec
un poulet de Bresse élevé au grain et en
pleine air une fois qu'on a dit ça
comment expliquer cet engoument pour ces
nouveaux produits alimentaires près de
20 % des Français déclarent en avoir
déjà consommé au moins une fois et bien
si ces nouvelles offres alimentaires
séduisent de plus en plus c'est parce
que globalement la viande on en mange
trop ce n'est pas bon pour notre santé
ni pour la planète et de plus en plus de
consommateurs en sont conscients on en
consomme en moyenne 85 kg par personne
et par an c'est moins qu'avant mais 85
kg c'est encore trop il a été démontrer
que la charcuterie et la viande rouge
augmentent les risques de maladies
cardi-ovasculair le diabète de type 2 et
aussi l'apparition de certains cancers
le cancer colorectal par exemple est
plus fréquent chez les personnes qui
consomment beaucoup de viande rouge pour
toutes ces raisons santé publique France
recommande de limiter la consommation de
viande à 500 g par semaine ce qui
correspond à TR ou 4 steaks par semaine
en France l'agriculture est le deuxième
poste d'émission de gaz à effet de serre
23 % du total et sur toutes les
émissions issues de l'agriculture les
3/4 proviennent de l'élevage parmi ces
gaz il y a le dioxyde de carbone mais
pas que l'agriculture produit aussi du
méthane et du protoxyde d'azote le
méthane est produit par les ruminants
les vages et les moutons dans leur
système digestif il est essentiellement
rejeté par la bouche quand ils éruent
quand ils rotent si vous préférez le
protoxyde d'azote lui est lié à la
fabrication et l'utilisation d'engrais
pour la production de fourrage et à
l'épendage des fumiers et des lisiers le
pouvoir de réchauffement global du
protoxyde d'azote et du méthane sont
respectivement 265 fois et 28 fois plus
important que celui du CO2 heureusement
ils disparaissent plus vite que le
dioxyde de carbone bien sûr toutes les
viandes ne polluent pas de la même
manière 2 émettent plus de gaz à effet
de ser que les autres il s'agit du bœuf
et de l'agneau la production d'un kg de
viande de bœuf émet 27 kg de gaz à effet
de ser la même quantité de viande
d'agneau 39 kg voici de la viande rouge
cette couleur typique de la viande de
bœuf est dû à une protéine la myoglobine
elle est présente dans la fibre
musculaire c'est elle qui stocke
l'oxygène à l'intérieur du muscle pour
le relâcher lors d'un effort physique
dans un steak végétal elle est remplacée
par des colorant r naturel et de
l'extrait de betterave ou de la poudre
de Grenade mais pour reproduire le goût
et la texture de la viande c'est une
autre paire de manch et pour cause d'un
côté on a du muscle autrement dit des
protéines animales de l'autre des
protéines végétal issu de légumes et de
légumineuse du riz des fèves des
poichiches des lentilles et même parfois
des haricot alors on est d'accord à la
base aucun de ces produits n'a goû de
viande et pourtant les fabricants de
steak végétaux ont surmonté cet obstacle
en ajoutant un extrait de plante la
légémoglobine il s'agit d'une protéine
extraite du soja qui contient une
molécule appelée l' non seulement cette
molécule donne à la légémoglobine un
aspect rouge vif car elle contient du
fer qui est à l'origine de la couleur du
sang mais elle lui donne aussi une odeur
et une saveur proche de celle de la
viande de bœuf pour la texture en
revanche c'est un peu plus compliqué ce
sont les fibres musculaires de la viande
qui la rendent souple et pour l'instant
on n'arrive pas à trouver de fibres
végétales aussi souple que celle de la
viande elles sont plus rigides et
donnent au steak végétal un aspect
légèrement friable parfois un peu pâteux
soyons franc c'est le point faible de ce
produit alimentaire mais contrairement à
ce que l'on pense ils sont aussi riches
en protéines 100 g de soja contiennent
36 g de protéines végétal contre 26 g de
protéines animales pour 100 g de bœuf
c'est également une bonne source de
fibre la viande elle en est dépourvue or
elles sont excellentes pour le bon
fonctionnement de l'intestin l'autre
alternative pour remplacer la viande
issue de l'élevage c'est la viande de
synthèse de la viande fabriquée en
laboratoire on dit aussi la viande in
vitro alors j'aurais bien aimé vous en
apporter et même la goûter devant vous
mais on n trouve pas encore en Europe
pour produire de la viande de synthèse
il faut un poulet ou une vache en
fonction de ce que l'on veut obtenir et
aussi une petite boîte comme celle-ci
une boîte de pétrie on s'en sert dans
les laboratoires pour cultiver toutes
sortes de micro-organismes des bactéries
des champignons des cellules en
l'occurrence on va y placer des cellules
souches prélevé par exemple sur du tissu
musculaire de vaches adulte ces cellules
qui ne sont pas encore différenciés on
la capacité étonnante de se transformer
en différents types de cellules neurones
globule rouge ou cellules musculaires
pour produire de la viande tout dépend
de la solution dans laquelle baignent
les cellules le fameux burger à 250000 €
dont nous avons parlé tout à l'heure a
été conçu de cette manière dans une
petite boîte de pét il était composé de
20000 fibres musculaires produites à
partir de quelques cellules souchees
plus incroyable sur le même principe une
start-up australienne a réussi à créer
cette année une boulette de viande à
partir de protéin de mamouth alors a
priori comme ça sur le papier la
viandine vitro présente pas mal
d'avantages n'étant pas issu de
l'élevage elle permettrait de réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
nécessiterait jusqu'à 95 % d'eau en
moins sans oublier que ce serait une
manière d'obtenir de la viande sans
avoir à abattre des animaux pour toutes
ces raisons on la surnomme clean meat
viande propre sauf qu'une étude récente
réalisée par l'Université de Californie
et publiée par la revue New Scientist
montre que l'empreinte carbone de la
viande artificielle pourrait être
beaucoup plus élevée que celle de la
viande de bœuf cette viande in vitro est
composé de nutriments qui doivent être
purifiés or le processus de purification
destiné à éliminer des toxines contenues
dans certaines bactéries et très poant
chaque kilogramme de viande de synthèse
pourraitêre engendrer 4 à 25 fois plus
d'émissions de gaz à effet de ser que la
viande de bœuf classique alors alors que
faut-il conclure de tout cela que l'on
mange trop de
viande assurément mais comment réduire
certains ont choisi de renoncer à la
viande pour la planète le bien-être
animal mais attention adopter un régime
sans viande ça ne s'improvise pas la
viande apporte de la vitamine B12 par
exemple qui contribue à la formation des
globules rouges et qu'on ne trouve dans
aucun aliment végétal certains
nutriments ne sont pas présents dans les
légumes ou les légumineuses ou alors ils
résultte d'association min
donc il est fortement conseillé de
consulter un médecin nutritionniste
avant de s'engager dans une telle
aventure surtout si on s'ilance avec des
enfants ou des ados en pleine croissance
attention aussi aux personnes fragiles
l'autre solution c'est de consommer
moins mais mieux on l'a dit santé
publque France recommande 500 g de
viande par semaine l'idée c'est de bien
choisir de contrôler son origine de
discuter avec son boucher en général il
sait où et comment l'animal a été élevé
c'est valable pour toutes les viandes du
bœuf à la volaille en passant par le
porc et l'anau et puis pour remplacer la
viande que l'on a retiré de certains
menus et bien il y a des protéines
végétales qui peuvent se présenter sous
la forme de steak de crêpe ou de nuggets
essayer mais n'attendez pas forcément de
ces plats qu'il se rapproche de la
viande classique en terme de goût et de
texture c'est une alimentation
différente qui propose d'autres saveurs
et d'ailleurs là aussi il y a à boire et
à manger les substituts de viande
n'affichent pas tous la même qualité il
s'agit souvent d'aliments transformés on
y trouve de l'huile du sucre du sirop de
glucose et de nombreux additifs
émulsifiant stabilisant et conservateur
voilà je vous laisse digérer toutes ces
infos si ça a du mal à passer n'hésitez
pas à revoir cette vidéo excellente
semaine à toutes et à tous et à très
vite pour une nouvelle vidéo épic
[Musique]
curieuse